all right
here's something a little bit uh a bit
more light-hearted something that
another thing I'm a few days behind on
this I realize
um but I think it's important to cover
because I do give female comedians a
hard time and yet here's an example of
uh one being funny you know actually
being funny this did make me laugh
but laughing at her entirely
to be clear so here's Chelsea Handler
with a startling admission if you
haven't heard this yet listen
I didn't know and this is true I didn't
know until I was 40 years old that the
sun and the moon were not the same thing
at times it's hard to believe but what
are you talking about it was I was
shocking to me as well I mean of course
it must have been more shocking to you
it was like I was in Africa we were on
Safari my sister and I were riding an
elephant and there was a man riding an
elephant for us because we don't know
how to ride an elephant yeah and my
older sister Simone looked up at this at
the at the sky and she said Chelsea
Chelsea look up it's not often you get
to see the sun and the moon at the same
time yeah
and I was like okay I was like
Scooby-Doo I'm like
I said and I go wait I go but they're
always together and as soon as I said
that she turned around she goes what did
you say and I was like oh shut up shut
up shut up I'm like I knew what I said
was wrong
I was like let's Cantor is that what an
elephant oh my God and um I and and she
looked at me she goes I need you and I
just tried to gloss over it I was like
never mind what I said I know and she
said no I need you to tell me what you
think is happening between the Sun and
the Moon
and I was like honestly I just assumed
when the sun went down it popped back up
as the moon you know
costume change
the man riding the elephant spoke no
English and went
a dumb American yeah
no no hey
don't put this on us another dumb
American
you're the only American in the country
who thinks that so don't don't try to
blame the rest of this but think about
how
and she's trying to pass it off as like
this silly little anecdote and you know
they're they're and yeah you know there
are things maybe we've all had
experiences of some little minute thing
that you didn't you know like you didn't
you didn't realize and then you learned
uh later in life because nobody told you
I don't know I'm sure people can come up
with examples like that
but think about how stupid you have to
be
that if it's
incomprehensibly stupid
to think that the sun is the same thing
my three-year-old daughter knows that
that's not the case she understands that
there are two different entities I mean
I know a lot else about them but she
knows that at least
so the level of stupidity that I mean
how do you how does she breathe like how
I mean how does she walk does she can
she tie her own shoes these are all live
questions now that we need answers to
how do you function in society how is it
that you've never like
there are some things that even if
you're not taught directly you'll just
you you encounter the realities that you
encounter in life
how do you avoid that one
but
this is also I didn't look it up but
Chelsea Handler I'm assuming at least
graduated high school
so this is the uh this is the modern
education system for you that it's
possible in the modern education for
someone to graduate to go through the
education system and to come out on the
other end not knowing that the Moon and
the Sun
are two different Celestial entities
and that'll do it for this portion of
the show as we move over to the members
block hope to see you there if not talk
to you tomorrow
rather on Monday
Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]